hacía seis años no se celebraba la
cumbre de líderes de norteamérica los
temas principales que abordaron andrés
manuel lópez obrador de mexico yo centro
de canadá y yo baile en eeuu fueron la
crisis migratoria la integración
comercial y económica y la lucha contra
el cambio climático y la pandemia el
principal mensaje de el mexicano lópez
obrador fue el agradecer a joe biden por
tratar de avanzar con la reforma
migratoria en su país que le permita un
camino viable a la ciudadanía más de 11
millones de inmigrantes indocumentados
que hay en este país sobre el tema amlo
agregó que dada la dificultad que tiene
eeuu para llenar sus puestos de trabajo
era muy oportuno considerar que
migrantes legalizados ocuparán estos
cargos y así entonces aliviarán la
presión que tienen las empresas
estadounidenses adicionalmente los tres
mandatarios acordaron trabajar
conjuntamente para lograr reemplazar
importaciones con productos locales y
dejar así la dependencia -china eeuu y
canadá recordemos tienen la frontera
comercial más grande del mundo en la que
se comercializa cerca de dos mil
millones de dólares al día en productos
y servicios cabe mencionar también que
la próxima cumbre de líderes
norteamericanos será en mexico en el